bien sûr voilà c'est un bilan dans
comment j'ai tué mon père dans un skate
2 bat pavillon dira quelque chose c'est
con quand vous dites sketches se sont
pas vraiment des scalps de l'homme cedh
et monologues
voilà vous êtes prêts pour lentilles
portrait chinois
oui je sais on ne couche pas dans le
qinghai
si vous étiez un défaut un défaut
d'attention se rentrer sur scène la
braguette ouverte par exemple par
exemple si c'est une injure à fast food
en bord de mer une maladie la sinusite
une partie de mes cachets je les donne
pour la recherche pour la sinusite un
vrai mais parce que toutes les maladies
importantes été prises comme le sida ou
moi j'ai aussi trouvé une maladie en
proportion que ma notoriété
si vous étiez une guerre une guerre la
guerre de troie pour parce que voilà ce
que la guerre de troie n'aura pas lieu
avec son soutien à vis le nooyi sme le
nooyi sme c'est parce que c'est celle
arnouil non le vous allez mélangisme
vous connaissez ouais bien sûr un
fétichisme le voile rigide parce que
tout ça est le no x mais c'est une
partouze où les gens viennent déguisés
en nouilles
ah oui non ça vient des états unis c'est
très simple moi j'en ai fait une un
billet en coquille est des franchement
je ne veux pas je me suis éclaté c'est
arrivé en france en janvier 2002 falloir
un petit peu patienter mais il ya un
truc qui va arriver aussi en france
astrid la télé le zyban été tués
il paraît que c'est radical haoues moi
je cherche le moyen magique pour arrêter
de fumer parce que j'ai aucune volonté
il paraît qu'il faut un petit peu de
volonté et ça agit directement sur les
cellules qui sont dépendants du thème du
tabac
pas de bouton dedans ni nicotine et par
extension alors il ya le nudisme qui va
arriver en france il ya le zyban 15 ans
médias le terrorisme aussi
préparez vous bien que vous étiez une
arme tarte à la crème un supplice chef
opérateur sur un film porno c'est un a
fait 120
elle est oubliée ouais c'est vrai billon
oui c'est une cicatrice new york
jean majeau vous dire je suis embêté
parce qu'il a été très brillant et moi
j'ai été trés mules et vous voulez vous
aussi voulez je vous dise pourquoi c'est
parce que je m'étais préparé sur des
trucs comme des préservatifs
je pensais me sucer ses baisers sont
atteintes par des îles caméra sur jean
d'ormesson est ce que vous pensez de
sucer c'est tromper je suis pas premier
ministre est là qu sur quoi vous
m'interrogez sur l'académie je suis
imprévisible gens normaux gens je lui ai
vous avez été très bien puis djamel vous
a aidé et de saint joseph binguimalet
avec plaisir si vous étiez un dictateur
un dictateur l'audimat
ouais bonne réponse est non il était 17
heures les missionnaires
si vous êtes une infirmité quelqu'un qui
mémorise par les prénoms
ouais mon père et il me donnait des noms
de mes frères et le mien s'appelle david
bernard stefan wey et encore ça s'est
amélioré parce que avant on avait un
chien qui se répète ici c'est avec quoi
je vous signale que ça s'acquiert ceux
dont la saq est ce que moi je
connaissais les prénoms avant et puis
tout à coup ils m'échappe mais le vôtre
ou le lumia ça va encore on peut dire
qu'il est facile si vous étiez un
assassin à l'assassin londres est ce que
vous savez que quand landre a été
condamné à mort a tout à voir dernière
minute il ya un prêtre que d'ivoire et
qui lui a dit mon enfant pourra vous
l'apporté lescoat religion est ce que
vous croyez à dieu ce que vous croyez à
une autre vie et l'envoie répondu oh mon
père est ce que vous trouvez que c'est
le moment de plaisantes
si vous étiez un microbe un microbe pas
le microbe c'est difficile parce que par
exemple claudia schiffer grippe et je
n'embrasse way michèle alliot marie en
pleine santé je la touche il était une
torture
une torture passé une nuit en copain
avec une fille sublime
ouais ça vous est déjà arrivé à tout le
monde
1 je le promets je ne touche pas tu
devrais métallique qui me touchait pas
le cas
bien lieu si vous étiez une humiliation
humiliation à une fois j'étais c'était
dans un dîner j'étais très jeune à dîner
chez un copain et j'étais tellement gêné
d'être atteint avec les parents de mon
copain que je me suis mis à à caresser
le chien sous la table et à un moment
donné je me suis aperçu que c'était la
jambe de la mère de mon copain c'était
dans les années 80 il ya des des jupes
avec des morceaux de laine comme ça
voyez comme vous quand vous vieillissez
vous croyez vous caresser la jambe
dernière question stéphane c'est bien
stéphane tu peux pas faire comme votre
père vous n'êtes pas david
si vous étiez mort la mort de james dean
à l'âge de jeanne calment millions
j'ai mon verre avec
charles berling d'arrêt
à gaza
bon alors c'est pas de la régionale 1